anybody who has teenage boys - knows
that they lie lie lie that's all they do
and you know how you know they're lying
because their mouth is moving they lie
but here's the thing
sometimes you don't bust them with all
of them and sometimes their lies are so
good that you're almost proud of them
you know what I mean you're like and
don't do that again
that's my [ __ ] boy you know my son's
best he ran a game on me ran a game on
me my wife and I we went to Hawaii for
vacation and my parents came to stay
with him so when we come back we got a
DirecTV bill a month later and there's
$200 worth of porn charges and we're
looking at the bill right my wife and I
and I'm mad I'm mad I'm mad mad right
the dude needs to be taught a lesson
because porn is free like how dumb do
you have to pay I got porn in my pocket
24 hours a day I'm worried about it as a
human being if he's still paying for
porn that is the dumbest [ __ ]
[ __ ] I've ever heard up I'm worried
about him walking around in this world
if he's still paying for porn like I
wasn't gonna do that I tell my wife I'm
like I gotta go down and talk to him
this is so dumb but here's the deal I
feel like this is gonna be a quick
conversation cuz his mo when he lies is
he'll lie and then if you just show him
facts he's like yo those men and that's
it so I have the facts in my hand I have
to build in my hand so I figure it's
gonna be a quick conversation so I go
down into his room and I'm like hey man
did you go Joe I go you know anything
about this and here's how I could tell
he was gonna lie to me cuz as soon as I
held up the bill he bent over and he
squeaked it like he couldn't read all of
a sudden he was like
I just started shaking his head like he
had never seen that language before you
look and then he said something so
ridiculous he goes yo I'm not familiar
I'm like what the [ __ ] does that mean
you're not familiar you don't recognize
English so you don't know what that is
and he goes I'm not sure what that list
of stuff is how my gets boring he goes
oh I know you don't know anything about
that farm you guys know I know you
didn't order that point there's no I
know cuz I'm looking at the dates when
the porn was ordered and it's when your
mom and I were out of town and the only
people at the house were you and Grandma
and Grandpa
so it was either you Grandma and Grandpa
and he looks me right at Minnie goes
well they do like each other a lot I was
like take it easy there man you know you
talk about my mom right you talk about
my mom right now I said you take my mom
watches porn he goes no I didn't say
that you said that and I'm like why is
he so confident I have the bill I have
it right here why and that's that okay
I'm gonna make him so uncomfortable that
he'll admit it and he doesn't want to
talk about porn with his dad so I guess
I'll just start reading off the titles
of the movies so I said to Mike are you
telling me that grandma grandpa
we're in my room watching anal party
three and this is the quote out of his
mouth he goes well the door was shut all
weekend
I thought are you saying my mom watches
anal he goes no you said that I never
said that
guys I walked into the room 100% sure it
was him now I'm at like 99 and then I
realized the reason he was so confident
you know why are you so confident
everybody the reason he was so confident
was the only way I can truly prove there
was him is it by call my parents
[Music]
and I say did you watch anal Part III in
my room and on the off chance they say
yes
I gotta burn the [ __ ] house down like
I can't live there as an adult male if
my parents are watching anal on your bed
you can burn that [ __ ] down so I need to
all of a sudden have come up become Tom
Cruise from a few good men like I needed
to know right so I decided that he's
gone all-in he knows I don't want to
call my parents the only way I can bust
him is if I go all in to so I'm like
okay I'm going all in with this and I
say to him I go man
you didn't order the porn you didn't
order the porn and then he did say what
every teenager says at least once and I
said you didn't order the porn and he's
like I wish you just believe me oh you
never believe me
oh hang on oh man I believe you and he
goes whoa because I figured I'm pushing
all my chips into the only way to get
him is to admit it is a get him into a
situation that he doesn't want to be so
I said yeah I believe you and I think
it's terrible that Grandma and Grandpa
are making you pay for their porn
he was a guard dig that's terrible dude
I say dude we should we came out of
hiding the shadows out there in the East
Coast we gotta call him out he was like
Rudy Hollings list let's like what do
you think man and I held up my phone I
go let's just get him on the phone and
he looks me dead in the eye any oohs
call them
and he goes no no no calm calm dad I
want to hear you call your parents and
ask them if they watched anal party
three in your room I want to hear you
ask that cave question call I go I'm
gone and he goes I'm right here
I was like so I start to dial one number
dial another number and he goes you
don't have your parents on speed dial
I said yeah I do I'm just taking I'm
going slow him giving you a chance to
come clean he goes oh okay
because I wouldn't say come clean when
you talk to them and I was like listen
guys if this is a fight he's landed
every [ __ ] punch so far and I'm like
okay I'm pressing another button press
another button guys I'm like and then
I'm gonna jump out of the window like
this is it for me bounce it press that
Knight button and he goes whoa I'll pay
for it and I said you ordered the porn
he goes no that was Grandma and Grandpa
I just don't want you to embarrass them
I think it's nice how much they like
each other
[Applause]
it lets me dead in the eye and he goes
we don't here and I was like yeah but
that wasn't satisfactory to me guys I
needed to hear him say he ordered the
porn right so we get into the outside of
his door and I'm on the outside of it
and I go hey I went before it before
before leave I'm gonna give you one last
offer I will pay the bill and give you
$200 all you got to do is say you heard
the point and he looks right at me and
he goes nope grab on grab on and now
every time he walks by my room and the
doors open he looks in and he goes I
wouldn't sleep on that bed like an
[ __ ]
[Music]
you